josh donaldson who's hitting behind
nelson cruz today
bullet up the middle cruz around third
they're gonna wave him home and the ball
bobbled in center by hill
and donaldson will deliver another two
out hit and the twins for the 50th time
in 91 games score first well you
shake up the lineup you move donaldson
down in the order into a run producing
spot and he immediately rewards you with
a one-nothing lead in this ball game he
hit this ball hard i think if he comes
up with it clean he might actually had a
play
on cruz at home plate and
we were showing cruz and he was
signaling to first base coach tommy
watkins
trading out for a run if he sends me
home keep him going to second to try and
get him to cut the ball off there's
kenta maeda has been better recently and
i think no coincidence that has to do
with him wearing his socks high of
course but no i think it's the health
and and you know continue what he's been
doing if you had a good run of starting
pitching recently and giving you guys a
chance to win and i think obviously
having a little more life on that
fastball helps
fastball at 91 gets a swing and a miss
23rd pitch for maeda here in this first
inning with grossman going and it's a
fastball that beats cabrera a couple of
strikeouts in a scoreless first the
twins lead it one to nothing two away
here in the second here's anderton
simmons right back up the middle on the
backhand what a stab by castro and he
throws him out it saves a run
and that is a highlight reel play
on the backhand up the middle this one
was destined for center field but harold
castro and a sliding save
six homers 28 runs driven in for aquil
badu so far this season here's the 1-0
fly ball right center field
find the gap
one run is home
short will score derek hill will score
clears the bags and it's 3-1 detroit
foot down keeps the hands back that is
right there's hand hit me and he does
there's a strikeout of scope but it
comes a batter too late the tigers get a
basis clearing triple from badou and
it's three to one
and he got 91 past grossman going away
oh he got
strike on a fastball in got a fastball
away right here chasing off the plate
immediately turned around and looked at
one point on fire tripp gibson and asked
him if this pitch was a strike or not
but this had good run to it do you see
that ball kind of take off when it was
about halfway to home plate and it's
been very disciplined
well you kind of have that internal
clock as the game's going along going
all right if we're going to come back in
this game
here's how we're going to do it you know
you get down by five early as you said
this almost feels like being down by
more than just two runs donaldson skies
one to deep left field very well hit and
it is gone
donaldson's 14th of the year
and it's a 3-2 ball game he has both run
batted ends runs batted in on the day
yeah another hard hit ball hit a bullet
up the middle for a single rbi single
first time up here he just turns on this
ball hits this all about a mile in the
air but you wonder if
you're trying to squeeze some extra outs
out of him with the two-run lead
you want him to face kiro off after this
but you can't sleep on donaldson he's a
guy who can make you pay and he did
exactly that now we're saying that lead
seemed a little uncomfortable you get it
back to one run now you're just one
swing away
good pitch there the splitter gets a
swinging strike three but as you see it
you know you look at and you go okay
well some crazy things have happened
this year the bullpen has given up far
more runs than expected and
you haven't won the games where you've
had the lead and all these different
things well executed split right here
below the zone
the angels said coming to the town
they've got one of the premier players
ohtani and trout rindon they signed in
the offseason
those are three all-star caliber players
and we're gonna miss struck him out a
couple of strikeouts for maeda here
three up three down
he's retired now seven in a row and now
they're loaded up for nelson cruz and
the last guy i think you want to face if
you're the detroit tigers is nelson cruz
with the bases loaded
off the middle
castro can't field it cleanly and the
game is tied simmons coming in from
third base and give crews credit for an
rba i doubt they would have gotten two
because of the shift i'm not sure they
had anyone in position to cover second
base leaves his feet and then was
looking to make a flip to short but c
short is so far over
in the shift that it was a race between
him and larnick to even get to second
base to get that force out there get
back in the same situation now you got a
chance to go ahead right here with
donaldson who's had two great swings so
far in the second game of this
doubleheader here it is
go get it call it mick bingo double play
there you're getting over i love it
bingo bango bingo
one and two to hill then badou and scope
and split change for a swinging strike
three one away eight in a row
with i should add
five strikeouts for maida
just want to miss got him nice fastball
back-to-back strikeout still got one
more big out to get with a runner in
scoring position here
hill was hit by a pitch back in the
second scored on the three-run badou
triple
to right field caught by larnick a
bullet to right field for the third out
and we'll head to extra innings tied at
three and as with two
wild pitches on the year
oh when it gets to the back stop here
comes gordon and he'll score his third
wild pitch of the year and the twins
take the lead and so the pitch
runner works out because he's able to
tag up on a fly ball to center field
gordon is and you're out there you have
to trust your catcher catcher majorly
catcher
should be able to block this ball
you know what pitch is coming
you set up in that high stance and
fortunate that second run didn't come
around to score right there but a tough
pitch to block this ball skipped on him
but at the same time in the big leagues
with the tire the go ahead run on third
base you got to be able to block that if
he gets first and third i wouldn't be
surprised if maybe they go with that
safety squeeze ship
take the tie at home and move on
the payoff
right side
we are tied jonathan skull comes through
derrick hill steals third
makes minnesota bring the infield in
just a little ground ball and you got a
tie game great fundamental
here you go miggy
[Applause]
here's the 2-2
in the air to shadow center
no
hustling in it's going to drop
scopes
[Applause]
it's a big swing
and max kepler breaks back and jonathan
scope was running all the way
a rush quick throw off target
and a hustling scope
wins it
a lot of guys jogging these you just
never know you never know he's running
pretty good he's reading it
he's going
[Applause]
george lombard
will remember this game as his first
making a decision like that and getting
the game winner
very cool boys unexpected the 14th
game-winning
rbi for miguel cabrera and it gives the
tigers
a 5-4 win